10 out of 10 personal finance experts
will tell you to max out your 401k but
if you actually when i run the numbers
i'm like uh i'm not sure that's the best
decision for everybody so all right
let's um let's maybe just start with
like your perspective on uh personal
finance and on financial markets i think
what's very interesting about you is
that you take a
data-driven approach and there's a whole
bunch of things that most people i would
say uh hold as truth or hold as these
like uh
religious almost perspectives on
financial markets and you've been able
to time and again
either disprove or kind of shed further
light on why maybe it's not completely
uh the only way to think about it and so
what is your process like do you find
things people say and then go look at
the data do you start with the data and
then come to conclusions and then
compare them like what's that process
look like
honestly it's a little bit of both
sometimes i just like i'm like you know
what why don't we actually check this is
this actually true for example one of
the big points out there is like oh you
should max out your 401k and so
i'm like okay well let's see like how
much of actual benefit do you get from
maxing from going like above the match
right and i see like oh you're getting
like 70 bips here 0.7 percent most 401k
plans are something like 50 bips and
fees so really after like the all-in
fees you're getting 20 bips you're gonna
lock up your capital till you're 60. and
i'm like is that really worth it like 20
bips is that worth it and so like once
you start to question just like a lot of
the things that it's kind of like the
elon musk type of idea going back to
first principles like i love that idea
because it's like we've been told so
many things like basically you know i
would say 10 out of 10 personal finance
experts will tell you to max out your
401k but if you actually when i run the
numbers i'm like uh i'm not sure that's
the best decision for everybody so it's
just kind of going back to first
principles and saying like what's
actually true what's not true right
versus what the media tells us right so
go back to this thing because i think
this first let's just start off real hot
this violates every single thing
anyone's ever been told by a financial
uh advisor which is uh they do get the
advice max out all of your uh retirement
um and your argument from the data is
that there's only a point seven percent
advantage every year from doing that
well explain what that means like where
do you get the point seven uh percent a
year from
so that that particular analysis i'm
comparing a roth 401k to just like
having that money in a brokerage account
and just managing it well like you're
not buying in and out all the time
you're just like buying and hold over a
long period and so you're basically
avoiding capital gains that's the one
thing if you that 15 capital gains
compounded over a lifetime that's end up
being like 0.7 percent a year annualized
right that's the difference we're
getting now technically you're like what
if i use a traditional or a versa roth
it gets a little bit more convoluted
there but like no matter what you're
gonna have to pay income tax we know
that like at some point either pay at
the beginning with the roth or you pay
it later with a traditional right when
you're in retirement so assuming those
rates are the same they won't be
necessarily depending on a lot of
factors but let's assume those are the
same the only thing i care about is the
capital gains tax which is the second
tax which is what you avoid by having a
401k versus having it in like a
brokerage account a taxable account so
i'm just like looking at that difference
and i'm saying like how big is that like
i took a took put the same amount of
money in every year and did that for
like 30 or 40 years and i said look at
the end like how much more money do i
have and like that difference and that
difference is about like point seven
percent compounded you know all of us
equal but that's assuming no difference
in fees it's assuming the same funds
everything is assumed to be the same but
once you actually look like the 401ks
have fees and you have to like you don't
get to choose your investments there's
like only a certain set of options you
have right so when you take all that
into account like it's the benefits even
smaller in some cases and some people
have to pay one percent a year in their
401k right it's like if you're paying
over 70 bips in your funds you're
actually getting negative alpha for
everything above the match right like
think about that like it's just it's
just not doable so it doesn't make sense
to me so when you think about that you
you find this data point right you're
like hey maybe this isn't exactly as
clear-cut as most people want it to make
it seem
what
do people
go and do where there is an advantage
like do you have data in terms of like
from a retirement standpoint are there
specific structures that they should
actually look at where the math seems to
be a little bit more in their favor
well iras are much better because you
can pick your investment options right
so like that alone if you can pick your
investment options you can pick lower
cost stuff now if you have low cost
stuff in your 401k it's basically the
same as an ira that's one piece of it
the other thing is like
um with the 401k like you're putting
that money in over time and like
because you can't pick the investment
options that's a piece of it that's a
little annoying the other thing people
can do is like you can if you manage it
well in a brokerage account like i don't
know if people know this but for example
and a single individual you can pull out
40 something thousand dollars a year if
you have no other income
tax rate is zero right and then if you
have like even with the standard
deduction it's like 50 50 grand a year
and tax rate is zero on capital gains do
you have a couple you can pull out a
hundred grand a year and assuming you
have no other income tax rate is zero so
like think about that like a brokerage
account that's well managed you can be
pulling out 100k a year with no tax so
in that case like a 401k would be even
worse right so like that's kind of the
process i go through i'm like looking at
this and i'm saying like is this does
this make the most sense for people yes
or no and so that really depends right
in certain cases it can also make sense
like for example if you're in a high tax
state now and you know you're gonna be
in a low tax state in retirement it does
make sense to probably max because
you're going to be avoiding the in a
pre-tax
retirement account because you're going
to be avoiding those high taxes now and
then paying the low taxes later so
that's kind of the there's different
ways to think about it though so you can
pull out of a brokerage account
40 50 000
as an individual as long as you have
zero income without paying any taxes on
it yep that is a true statement as long
as you have no other income only your
only income is your capital gains let's
say you're you'll save a hundred so you
have a million dollar portfolio let's
say it's paying you five percent of you
to make the math you get 50 grand right
so it's paying you 50 grand in your
income tax rate is zero you have no
other income though if you have any
other labor income or anything else then
you're going to start paying taxes on it
but like tax rate is zero so you're like
why you're like why do you need a 401k
when you can put into a brokerage
account and if you just grow it big
enough like getting that yield and then
you just don't pay tax on it like that's
the current law of course the law could
change but that's the current law so
yeah it's fascinating one of the things
that is uh definitely a theme of these
conversations is just like these rules
are applicable to everybody whether
you're a billionaire or literally you
know you're on unemployment right every
single person these rules are available
it's just a difference of knowledge and
then also uh the ability to execute some
of these strategies but that's something
that you know once people know about it
they can go execute it themselves
obviously check with an accountant etc